what are what is going to be the
reaction of those who've been out on the
streets you know to this parliamentary
vote and also is Iraq in a position
today to defend its sovereignty if
foreign troops were indeed to leave the
country well if anything if what their
demands have been anything to go by this
is not going to be welcomed by all of
these people who were demanding an end
to foreign influence especially Iranian
influence in Iraq Sofia as you saw those
protesters in Tahrir Square at least 500
of them have been killed in the last few
months as Iraqi government carried out a
crackdown when they tried to enter the
Green Zone and then the Iraqi government
allowed the popular mobilization forces
to go in and essentially lay a siege
around the US embassy compound so it is
a divisive issue it is not being
welcomed already by these groups
especially the Kurds in the north who
boycotted this session this the many
Sunnis in in the far-flung areas outside
of Baghdad they don't want this US
presence to end because they see it as a
guarantee for their rights they don't
trust the Iranian backed forces they
accuse Iranian backed forces of carrying
out a lot of sectarian crimes they say
after the defeat of ISIL so it is an
issue which is going to be playing out
in the next hours and days in Iraq
because it is not something that every
Iraqi agrees or disagrees with what this
has done this assassination of Qasem
Soleimani and havana el Mohandas is that
it has United people in saying that
there needs to be and an end to the
impunity with which the United States
operates in Iraq he also heard it from
the iraqi prime minister himself they
saying that sulemani was coming to
europe with a message from iran he was
going to meet him in the morning because
what he was assassinated saying that
this is not the mandate of the US forces
and not the mission that he had agreed
upon and saying that his priority number
one is to end the presence of foreign
troops in Iraq whether it's going to
happen how long does it going to take it
is going to play out in the new in the
next few hours and days thank you for
that or sama bin Javed live for us in
Baghdad Lawrence Korb is a former
assistant secretary of defense and he's
going to give us his reaction I guess
Lawrence first of all to this decision
by the Iraqi parliament to expel foreign
troops including US troops what
implications for the US military
presence in this region well it's not
surprising because even before we
assassinated soleimani we had launched
attacks on several bases in Iraq over
the opposition of everybody in the Iraqi
government the president the prime
minister at the Foreign Minister the
Ayatollah and then of course the the
Iraqi government has already condemned
these attacks and so it's not surprising
that they're asking us to leave and this
is I think a consequence of not thinking
through when you take an action you say
well soleimani was bad we got them yeah
but now you might not be able to fight
Isis which is a bigger threat to the US
and its interest you've also turned both
the Iraqi people and the Iranian people
against the US before this the Iraqis
were demonstrating to get a rim out of
Iraq and the Iranian people were
demonstrating because of all of the
problems that they have now they're both
you know against the United States and
this is happening as as patty said
thirty five hundred US troops are being
deployed to the region to protect US
assets and US interests what's going to
happen to them is this decision by the
Iraqi parliament does go through and
he's approved by the government well the
question is do you bring him home the
president can say as he did in Syria
well we've defeated Isis I'm bringing
bringing them home but you know it's
important to keep in mind despite what
the president said if you count the
people on the carrier battle groups that
we've deployed to the Persian Gulf the
forces we sent to Saudi Arabia after the
oil facilities were bombed we've got
about 20,000 troops in there from a
president who said he was going to get
us out of the region if anything he has
increased that and he's undermined what
the Pentagon says no we don't want to
worry about the Middle East anymore we
need to worry about China and Russia
they're our main strategic competitors
so do you think there's a clear and
solid
strategy here or is this just you know
they're just doing this on a day-by-day
basis
yeah there's no strategy in fact when
they presented the options to the
president and they put the killing of
the the killing of the the Iranian
general on top I'd say that he wouldn't
select that so it's more likely he'll
select some of the more reasonable
options they were surprised when he
accepted the Soleimani you know
assassination and they were not prepared
for it okay thank you very much for
speaking to us Lawrence Korb live there
in Washington DC what will it mean for
Iraq first I think that's probably the
most important news we've heard since
the assassination of Qasem Soleimani in
fact I would argue this is probably the
most important news that we've had since
2003 since an occupied Iraq because the
idea of Iran and Iraq coalescing against
the United States to push their own
states out of Iraq that will probably
create a new center of power around
Tehran that if of course if the Iraqis
decide to go along whether you want that
will probably be a formidable challenge
to the United States and everyone else
in the region so this is the big issue
because everything else fully is a
buster and we've heard the last 24 48
hours a lot of bluster a lot of threats
and counter threats and retaliations and
I want to bomb 52 and about 48 and this
and that and this is all of course
important and they could escalate and
this there could be a mission creep here
even rhetorically speaking if the
terrorists doesn't work we'll hike up
the deterrence if force doesn't work
killing suleimani maybe more force would
work but in the end of the day all of
that is bluster the big thing the big
transformation is what will happen in
Baghdad I would pay more attention to
Baghdad than to the bluster that we've
been hearing but you know you say that
Iraq I mean if he rock is turning its
back to the Americans now the Iraqi
government so Iran is their only choice
left as an ally but as we've seen on the
streets of Baghdad and Mosul in the else
we're in Iraq protesters there the
people the Iraqi people don't want
Iranian influence either absolutely so
and in fact Iraq does have other options
it's most important option is its Arab
hinterland I think every Arab country
now would die to join Iraq help Iraq
even its Saudi emirati
Kuwaiti neighbors would be more than
happy to chip in in order to keep in
Iran at bay so Iraq does have options
Iraq Iran is a rich country and despite
the occupation of the United States and
the meddling of Iran it remains to be a
solid sovereign country and is and has
more than capable people in order to you
know build the economy build the country
and so on and so forth but everyone does
have influence in Iraq and this is the
big thing and this is the big story for
us between the United States and Iran
the United States walked according to
strategy to geopolitics Iran dependent
on its geography its close relations
it's the religion she is on all sorts of
connections cross border with Iraq that
allowed it so much influence within the
country the question is will it use it
or abuse it clearly a lot of people
think it's all of abuse going on in
terms of its relationship with Iraq so
what options then does Iran have now
following the assassination of sulemani
it has to respond somehow if it doesn't
respond it will be seen as weak
absolutely but it doesn't want to risk
an all-out war with the Americans either
given that they're already engaged in
other conflicts in the region in Yemen
in Syria when and what do you expect
their response to be what is clear to me
and contrary to all that I don't want to
say conventional wisdom but certainly
the apocalyptical predictions about
World War 3 and about original war I
don't think that's gonna happen mostly
because I don't think Iran wants to go
head-to-head with the United States the
last time another power in the Middle
East went to head to the United States
it was destroyed regime and country and
that's Iraq in 2003 I think
will will avoid a confrontation with
that with the United States at any cost
what it will do it will continue what it
did in the past which is low intensity
warfare proxy conflicts through its
allies and clients in the Middle East
and it has wide range of issues of
possibilities through clients whether it
is in Yemen in in Lebanon in Syria and
Iraq and so on and so forth and and the
United States still largely exposed and
a good number of countries and that's
what president from wants to do he
doesn't want to pull out of the Middle
East he wants to pull out of the hot
spots of the Middle East and just to
remind people around the world about
something very similar
not only the dances do that in Somalia
and Lebanon that's what Israel has been
cleverly doing in Gaza and Lebanon in
Syria pulling out troops from Lebanon
and Gaza and then using drones guided
missiles Air Force cyber and so and so
forth to hit its enemies so not pulling
out really redeploying right the idea is
to read the play in the United States
when it as your guest said before when
it redeployed out of Syria didn't read
the point send it back to the United
States
it really deployed two ships to Navy to
the various bases it has in the region
it has a six feet and the fifth fleet
still in the Gulf and in the
Mediterranean and by the way just so
we're all clear on some strategic one or
one the United States needs to stay in
the Middle East because it doesn't want
Russia and China to come into the Middle
East with the world - just two simple
figures China imports more than half of
its oil from the Middle East Japan
importantly 90 percent of its oil from
the Middle East if you want to control
the energy sources of Japan and China
what what should you do what you should
control a lot of the ins and outs of the
Middle East in order to put your
competition in check if you want to have
an advantage over China you're you
maintain control that at least my on
thank you very much as always very good
to get your insight on this